[Arabic recitation]
as the author took us through
the most common
method or the most common way that our
prophet Sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would make
ghusl.
would bathe.
We mentioned that the most
central narration
amongst the scholars with respect to the
prophet's wudu, the description of his
wudu,
is the narration of who?
No.
His wudu.
Uthman.
And his most and the most comprehensive
detailed description that is usually
used as the center piece
of building the
chapters
and rulings of ghusl
are taken from the narration of Now say
it. Aisha.
And we mentioned that narration
yesterday. Now there are some additions
here and there.
Scholars have one of two choices when
they write a book.
When they cite a narration
and they wish to present an argument,
there are two ways of doing this.
The first way is the way that the
earliest scholars used to write.
And that is that they will not change
the wording
of a narration
from the chain that it has come from.
So let's say for instance,
to build a full picture of his ghusl
through and through, I need five
different narrations.
They will not mix those narrations
together
and then mention them. They will mention
each narration and then the reader puts
it together.
Because the
idea is
the author is writing for other scholars
and students.
If a student is not advanced enough to
be able to put that together, they
shouldn't be reading that book. They
should be still sitting with the
scholars learning verbally from them.
The second way, which is the way favored
mostly by
latter day scholars and
contemporary authors,
is that they will mention the full
description
and then they will cite
each point.
These are two different ways.
And this is called it magic Hadith.
It magic Hadith
means that you take two or more
narrations
and you put them together to make a full
picture
in the same place without citing them
separately.
And obviously this became more popular
when
became more popular when books were
written
after the second century after Hijrah
or the third century after Hijrah when
when the books of Hadith became
solidified and now people after the year
300, they no longer narrate narrations
by chain of narration anymore. Now the
chains of narration source back to the
books
Sahih al-Bukhari.
So for instance, if you open Sahih
al-Bukhari,
those are the narrations that go from
al-Bukhari
to the Prophet sallallahu alayhi
wasallam.
Al-Bukhari passed away in which year?
256.
After the third century, so around the
time of al-Tabari,
rahimahullah. He passed away in the year
310.
After that, people didn't narrate to the
Prophet anymore directly, sallallahu
alayhi wasallam. Why?
Who could imagine why?
The narration is huge. It's going to be
15 people between you
and him each time. Plus, the most major
narrations, which have been agreed upon,
have already been settled upon in those
major books.
So, now, an author doesn't narrate like
al-Bayhaqi, They don't narrate to
or Ibn Hazm
or al-Qurtubi. They no longer narrate
directly to the Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wasallam.
Now, they narrate from themselves to one
of the authors.
And then, they mention the narration,
continuing the narration from the
author.
This is how the science of Hadith has
grown. Now, why do I mention this in
this context? The reason for this is is
that now,
we are going to deal with additions to
this narration of Aisha.
The question is, why didn't he just
mention it altogether? Because this is a
classical way of
writing, the way that the earliest
scholars of Hadith used to write. This
book is written by
it's it's a it's a
summary, in largely a summary of Fiqh
us-Sunnah for Sheikh Sayyid Sabiq,
rahimahullah. However, it is from a
Hadith
perspective, meaning that the narration
is primary and the conclusions are
secondary and derivative of the
narrations. This book was written so
that a student could memorize all of the
most important and critical narrations
in the science of Fiqh. That's the
That's really why this book was written,
right?
So, now, the author, after having
mentioned the narration of Aisha, is
going to build on that. He's going to
add little additions here and there.
Okay?
A person may say, "Well, this is not
really
this is not really ideal. It's not the
most ideal way to to learn fiqh."
Correct.
Perhaps,
depending on which angle we're looking
at it from. However, this is a way.
And we don't change knowledge to
accommodate the end user. It's the
opposite, right? The end user rises
to the level of the knowledge at hand in
order to be able to internalize it.
[Silence]
Right? The the pillars of ghusl, when we
say the pillars, we mean the bare
minimum of ghusl is intention
with
washing the entirety of the body
with water, pouring water over every
part of the entirety of the body,
including what?
Including the mouth and nose. Okay.
And so, here the author says, "So,
making wudu before ghusl,
whoever does this, then this person has
done the most complete way of making
ghusl.
And whoever
does not make wudu before
completing his ghusl,
then this is okay. This is still a valid
ghusl. And this is something that the
Prophet Sallallahu alayhi wasallam would
occasionally do.
Who is Muhammad ibn al-Hanafiyyah?
Ibn
[Arabic recitation]
The son of Ali ibn Abi Talib. This is
one of Ali ibn Abi Talib's
grandchildren. But Muhammad
is referred to as Muhammad ibn
al-Hanafiyyah
to articulate that this is different
than al-Hasan wal-Husayn's
mother. Al-Hasan wal-Husayn's mother
[Arabic recitation]
another wife that he married after
Fatima, that is referred to as
al-Hanafiyyah, because she was from Bani
Hanifah.
rahimahullah ta'ala.
[Arabic recitation]
of
love and commitment
are so
battered and bruised
in this era.
The country with 90% divorce rates is
the country that simultaneously is the
most authoritative on love and
commitment. Interesting, right? The
country that yaps the most about how to
have a successful relationship and
marriage is the same country that can't
keep their
divorce rates below their marriage
rates. It's fascinating, but one of the
ideas is this is your soulmate.
This is your wife and this is your
husband and that's it. You were meant
for each other and nobody else, and
widows be damned, and divorcees be
damned. I mean, that's it. You're just
meant for each other. They could never
ever ever marry again.
Who was the prophet Sallallahu alaihi
wasallam's best
friend and
you know, confidant and wife
for
so many years, and all of his children
are from
Khadijah.
And then when Khadijah passed away, she
passed away in which year?
The 10th year after Hijra.
the 10th year after prophethood. And
what year did he get married again?
The 10th year after prophethood.
Ali ibn Abi Talib,
who was his
wife?
Fatimah.
And he had al-Hasan wal-Husayn, and they
were
two peas in a pod.
Lovebirds, right?
And then she passed away.
And how many wives did he marry after
her?
More than nine. Nine.
And how many How long did he wait till
after she passed away?
Some narrations make it 2 weeks. 2
weeks.
Why? How could he? How heartless? No.
The Muslim ummah needs children. It
needs families. It doesn't need people
moping around,
you know, woe is me, my pain is so
precious, my pain is so beautiful. We
don't need that kind of guy.
We need children.
We need men and women.
We need families. There are divorcees.
There are widows. They need husbands.
That's what this ummah is about.
What does that and love have to do with
each other? How does that conflict?
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala created the
human being in this way.
[Arabic recitation]
Ali ibn Abi Talib, al-Hasan, al-Husayn,
all of them.
All of them.
Uthman was married to whose daughter?
Huh?
The Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wasallam. She passed away and then what
did he do?
He married her sister. The Prophet
sallallahu alayhi wasallam said, "Here's
the second one."
And then when she passed away, he said,
"If I had a third, I would have married
her to him as well."
Why didn't he say, "Oh my beloved
daughters, you're breaking their hearts.
How could you? How dare you? We have
stuff to do here. We're not here in this
dunya to pitter-patter
and lollygag. We're here to have
families. We're here to make soldiers
for the ummah of Muhammad, scholars and
fighters. We're here to make
intelligent men and women, strong men
and women that will build up our build
up our ummah.
Right? This is This is how humanity has
thought.
Not This is not specific to Muslims, by
the way.
You know, Genghis Khan, he married so
many women
and had so many children
that they say that there is something
20 or 30% of all humanity today has
some lineage back to Genghis Khan.
On the earth, the whole earth.
Right? Why was he doing that?
Cuz he's trying to,
you know, increase
his nation. Now, he is not a good
character. He died the death of a dog,
right? And he was a killer and a
terrible person, but nobody pointed this
out and said this is the bad part of his
life. This was common. Every ummah
they find it a responsibility to have as
many children as possible. The Prophet
Sallallahu alaihi wasallam says,
He said, "Marry
the
loving
the tender and loving
fertile women
because I am going to
show you off
on the day of judgement to the rest of
the nations.
Make as many of you as possible.
Right?
And if you look at governments and
societies, when you trace those major
societies and ruling classes back,
99 times out of 10, they came from
where?
From one portion of the society having
more children than others.
Now,
so this is not this is a little bit of a
side issue, but this is not
conflicting with love at all. You can
love your wife and your wife can love
you, and that's fine. But we're here to
to get something done.
We are here to
make this path better and more beaten
for the nation that is to come after us
and the generations after us.
[Arabic recitation]